not that I know if any conflict still
exists anymore or not but have you
thought about trying to get the entire
Arrested Development cast into a room
together and just working them all out
just say give us however many weeks it
takes so we can squeeze out another
season unless that's not an issue I
don't think it would be an issue I don't
think III really don't I mean there are
obviously two people that had a blow-up
and it wasn't handled well but I do
believe those two people are you know
smart and and not even deep down just
even on the surface love each other and
respect each other and can work that out
as two people can and and you know were
we were very much like a family we were
together we 15 years we go back yeah
from when we started and anything can be
worked out with just discussion that
unobvious lee and unfortunately played
out in the public forum and then had a
life of its own because that's what
people that's how people one of the ways
people make money to these days is you
go and you talk about something that you
weren't a part of and you talk about it
you you opine and you've opine about a
person's comment and then you've still
you know and you start even filling in
stuff that wasn't even you weren't privy
to
you just presuppose a bunch of things
and that that's how people make money
and you get cliques and stuff and adding
motives that didn't exist yeah yeah yep
and and the two individuals I'm I'm 100%
convinced could work it out all of us
could work it out absolutely we're
friends we know each other we love each
other we have respect for each other it
just like in a family your family blow
up arguments happen people blow up and
yeah when things that are private are
played out in public and there's a whole
different a whole nother dynamic to it
yeah everybody else feels like they have
an investment in it and they have a say
and that this is now a bigger thing than
it would have been if it was just a
private yeah argument you know what
unfortunately there was that initial
argument then there was a thing that
that
only it didn't look good for a reason
because it wasn't good and when we
didn't handle it well but there's
another step that can obviously sure
several steps can happen after that you
get together after that and and we also
that was literally the end of a long
press thing and we were leaving so that
that we didn't even get that chance you
know everybody was emailing and talking
privately but not the rest of it played
out in the public forum and that's the
number good but yeah but that's I don't
think that's the issue that's not really
the issue are there is there other
issues yeah I just don't think we would
want the actors would want to work that
way again it was not a good working
situation and it's one things that I
think in no small part and light lent
itself to what happened on set
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM adage